Kim Kardashian and Kanye West are
planning to expand their family I'm
really excited about it a source close
to the couple tells et that the parents
of two have hired a surrogate to carry
their third child it's unknown if the
surrogate is already carrying Kim yays
child but et source says quote they are
excited to finally add to their family
my pregnancy has been so tough I don't
know how much more bad news I can handle
the 36 year old had notoriously
difficult pregnancies with both her
four-year-old daughter North and
one-year-old son st. still she has been
candid about wanting to get pregnant
despite the health risk having more kids
it's definitely going to be a struggle
I've gone through so much with really
bad deliveries that the doctors don't
feel like it's safe for me to conceive
again myself it's been a reoccurring
topic on Keeping Up with the Kardashians
well what are you leaning towards like
to think you would be pregnant again or
have a surrogate obviously I do want to
have my own baby yeah you know but I
feel like I truly don't know if my body
can handle it one more time in May both
Kim's mom Kris Jenner and Kim's older
sister Kourtney offered to be Kim
surrogate on the family show if I really
thought that I could carry it for you
and it would be born okay I would do it
in two seconds
[Music]